i started smoking weed again
and i started drinking again
it became um a daily thing vomiting on
the freeway
banned from hotels for life
should you have been at my wedding or
was it the right thing to happen
of you why couldn't i come ruin your
wedding
that's what you're asking my wife's day
okay this is her special can you this is
her netflix i'm one of those quiet
alcoholics yes right yeah and i say
positivities hmm i would i would have
walked by your wife and went you seemed
beautiful and tight tonight
yeah good that's good right
thank you thank you so much right and i
would go to the ladies and go buenos
dias you work this out dude yeah when
they throw the rice i cook it
you're gonna treat me like every other
white guy huh
with that [ __ ] joke you're gonna
treat me like every other white guy oh
asians cook right so
that's crazy bro